it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr john gartner who is
founder of duty to warn
and co-editor of rocket man nuclear
madness in the mind of donald trump
he has taught in the department of
psychiatry at johns hopkins medical
center for 28 years uh dr gartner
thanks for joining us again sure well
thanks for having me
so last time you were on you described
and pointed to
a number of sort of publicly available
instances that you believe raised
the serious concern of donald trump's
both possible cognitive decline
and what has been described occasionally
as a pre-dementia
state you also discussed some
personality issues that you believe are
noticeable about the president from
publicly available
audio video information in the months
since we've had you on
have your concerns grown or decreased
about this issue
they've grown they've grown dramatically
i think two things i would point to is
one
if you managed to catch his two-hour
cpac speech
he was openly rambling it just didn't
make sense it sounded like the
wild sort of gyrations and meandering
uh sort of thought disorder of someone
who really has something cognitively
wrong with them
and i remember when i first started
suggesting that he was unfit
because of his severe personality
disorder his malignant narcissism
which is the personality disorder that's
shared by most murderous dictators
i said well it's not like he's openly
flagrantly thought disordered
it's really more this severe personality
disorder
but of course if he were you know openly
schizophrenic or openly thought disorder
well then they people would think
that they could remove him under the
25th men but anything short of that
they wouldn't even and now actually we
are seeing a flagrant thought disorder
in the form of this gross cognitive
deterioration and still
people are normalizing it the most
recent example of course that you know
colbert was
joking about last night was this tim
apple comment
that seems innocuous and funny but it's
actually quite revealing
uh he's done this many times before
called people by the wrong names
uh you know in the fires of california
he said the fires were in pleasure
california not paradise california
he's missed mexed up done malprapisms
with people's names about a dozen
different times
so the thing about this tim apple thing
is it's not actually funny
it's actually revealing of someone who's
cognitive slippage is getting worse by
the day and
showing it more flagrantly every single
day
and people are so entranced with the
dear leader that he could literally be
a babbling idiot and then everyone will
just normalize it
so there's people who will hear us and
they'll say you guys aren't talking
about
dyslexia is it possible that if not all
but much of what we're observing could
simply be
dyslexia
i know that's the short answer
he may have dyslexia i know he can't
read
but the reason to suspect cognitive
pre-dementia
that is because we're seeing cognitive
decline
from his earlier baseline as i said last
time i was on the show if you look at
videotapes of him
in the 1980s he's quite articulate he's
got a
rich vocabulary his thought is
sophisticated he speaks in polish
paragraphs
now he can't complete a sentence without
derailing into some kind of irrelevancy
he really has trouble finding words his
vocabulary is very
thin he overuses um superlatives which
is one of the things we see with people
who have dementia everything's
tremendous or you know a shame or
you know because that just sort of
covers a wide multitude of of
of of things uh so we're seeing
a gross deterioration from his own
baseline
so for something like dyslexia that
would be something stable that had his
whole life
what we're seeing is someone who's a
shadow of his former self in terms of
his cognitive functioning
when it comes to the i want to get to
the tim apple thing in a second but when
it comes to some of these incidents
where he has
seemingly had trouble pronouncing words
so that there was the
uh god bless the united states and and
the jerusalem and that type of thing
which was
we were told could have been a denture
issue but then
really rich people usually don't have
dentures they have implants and then we
were later told he doesn't really have
dentures what what do you make of that
piece
no i i think that's a good example
that's also i think quite significant i
mean these are sort of hard neurological
signs these kind of
mispronunciations um also some of his
spelling errors that you know the
smocking
gun and uh uh and also some of his
neologisms uh neologism is a made-up
word like
fifi um you know these are really
not these aren't subtle signs of thought
disorder
these are the kind of things that if you
saw it in your uncle you'd be sending
him to the doctor
when we go back to the tim apple story
for a second one of the things that
i'm thinking about is this report from a
private meeting at mar-a-lago with
republican
donors where he reportedly said that
it was fake news i mean that he didn't
actually say tim apple that he was
saying
tim cook apple in this sort of quick way
and that it's all completely fabricated
that's almost more disturbing to me in
the sense that either he believes he can
convince people that that's the case
which shows some kind of disconnection
from reality
or he may actually remember it in that
way i don't know
if one or the other is more concerning
to you
well they're both concerning and with
donald trump in general
he is a pathological liar and he also
has
uh delusional thinking so at any given
moment you're unclear as to whether he's
simply telling a lie
uh which he does you know something like
he's done six thousand times during the
time he's been in office
or he's actually deluded or distorted um
disordered in his thinking and he
actually believes some of these
crazy you know conspiracy theories or
what have you
and the thing is is it's it it really i
think is somewhat fluid i think he
actually goes back and forth between
simply lying
and actually living in a fantasy world
and you're right both
are disturbing but what's even more
disturbing is that both are
have you noticed anything in terms of
time of day there are sometimes
considerations or
observational differences in people who
either have pre-dementia or other
cognitive decline where time of day
seems to be a big difference maker in
terms of sort of how they're able to
comport themselves have you
observed anything like that with the
president you know that's a really
fascinating and interesting question i
have not been able to sort of track his
behavior you know by the hour but
now that you mentioned it it would be a
good variable for us to pay attention to
and try to measure
because i wouldn't be surprised if you
know as happens with people who have
dementia if
not doing some sundowning where he's
getting worse at certain
times of the day especially around
sunset i remember there was that one
uh visual of him not being able to find
the car
uh when he got off the plane he was sort
of wandering around the tarmac
and i think that was around five o'clock
people were saying this looks like my
demented uncle you know sundowning
um we have a lot of examples of that
where he seems to be disoriented
you know on stage he doesn't know where
he is he doesn't know who's there he
doesn't remember if melania is there or
not there
and people are kind of steering him you
know in the right direction but he
looks confused and aimless there will be
people who listen to or watch this
interview who will say
hey guys hold on a second uh dr gartner
has not examined donald trump
dr ronnie jackson did they did something
called
the montreal cognitive assessment and
uh trump passed right so what what how
do we evaluate that defense
no it's actually an excellent question
the montreal cognitive assessment
is really a screening device for gross
dementia
uh it doesn't measure these more subtle
signs of cognitive decline so if you
think of a rock rolling downhill
it only goes one way it only goes down
but if it's halfway down the hill
it's not going to be sensitive that the
montreal
test not sensitive enough to catch that
level of deterioration after all this is
someone with an ivy league education
so his fund of vocabulary even if he
loses 70 percent of his words
he still has more words uh than say
someone with you know low average
intelligence um
you know if you look at the items on the
montreal cognitive assessment test
there are things like um can you
identify a camel
can you identify a lion uh can you say
three
numbers backwards um these are the kind
of things that if can you draw a clock
so these are sort of things that are
very very rudimentary
so you could have someone who's in an
advanced stage of cognitive decline
but who hasn't gotten so demented that
they need to be institutionalized
that would still pass the montreal
especially if they started out
with a high level of intelligence to
begin with as i said if you look at the
tapes of him you know people say no we
haven't examined him but we do
have him on videotape speaking and
behaving so we have observed behavior
you look at the way he behaved and spoke
in the 80s he looks like someone who is
two standard deviations cognitively
ahead of where he is right now
yeah we so well let's dig into that a
little bit more because the last time
you were on there were people who even
though we did address it
uh still were not sort of satisfied with
your answer we've talked about
this um uh idea i don't know if i should
call it a standard or a rule or a
protocol
whereby mental health professionals
should not make assessments about
individuals without personally examining
them and you pointed out that unless
donald trump is effectively
playing a character in every audio
visual record
that we can deduce
characteristics about reality from the
audio visual record can you address that
from a sort of mental health standards
and guidelines perspective and then
maybe more colloquially well just to
take a step back so the goldwater rule
really sprung from a lawsuit in 1964
when barry goldwater was running for
president
and a magazine fact magazine which is
now defunct ran a cert did a survey of
psychiatrists as to whether he was
mentally stable
and uh this is in the area of freudian
psychiatry
uh and so many of the psychiatrists said
he wasn't but the explanations they gave
is that he
had an unresolved oedipus complex he'd
been scarred by his potty training he
was a latent homosexual
very speculative kinds of uh ideas and
so i actually interviewed
the last living member of the ethics
committee from that era and he said look
we didn't want people making
irresponsible claims about
public figures that did that weren't
evidence-based and that was why they put
that rule in also they didn't want to
make the profession look foolish or
leave it open to lawsuits
but then in the 1980s we switched to a
different diagnostic system
the dsm system which is based on
observable behaviors
all of our diagnostic criteria are based
on observable behaviors
well we can observe donald trump's
behavior
uh we can observe him on we observe him
on t we've all observed him on tv for
hundreds of hours
we observe his social media postings and
also
we have what we call psychiatry
informants people who have worked in the
white house
who've written memoirs or have given
interviews describing their observation
of his behavior you know there was a
hashtag 25th amendment
inside joke going on within the oval off
within the white house itself
of his own aids making you know kind of
slap
your forehead sort of um observations
about the things that he would do that
seems so grossly disordered so it's not
just an
act the people who are closest to him
are even more alarmed apparently
because they do see more close up how
disordered his behavior
his personality and his thinking truly
is
so what's important to understand is
that the
rule was put into place for good reason
people shouldn't make irresponsible
public
statements but it didn't it wasn't
intended to be an overall gag order
and it's not saying that we can't make
intelligent inferences about someone's
behavior if we can observe their
behavior and get
information from other people who are
observing their behavior so all of these
comments that we're making are based on
things that we can see with our own eyes
and that people who up close to him can
see with their own eyes
dr gartner last thing i want to touch on
i've been making the case that
whether or not there is a case for
impeachment against the president
at this point only 20 months from the
2020 election
the most direct path to his removal is
just voting for somebody else in
november of 2020.
along the same lines when we think about
the 25th amendment and removal for being
unfit
from a purely practical perspective are
you also of the mindset that
that is an uphill battle and the most
direct path is just voting him out in
2020
well the reason the most direct path for
getting rid of him is voting out in 2020
is because we have the most thoroughly
corrupt political party in the history
of our nation
the current republican party that would
not remove him
not can he shoot someone on fifth avenue
he could
commit mass murder on fifth avenue and
they would not remove him
this has really become a fascist party
who will unite behind the leader no
matter how evil
no matter how dishonest no matter how
destructive no matter how we immoral his
behavior
and so i think i disagree with nancy
pelosi in the sense that i think
it's actually their constitutional duty
to impeach him given that he is not only
committed
you know actually if you read the
constitution we always talk about high
crimes and misdemeanors
i'd like to point out that the
constitution that's not exactly what it
says
it says that a president should be
removed for treason
corruption high crimes or misdemeanors
high crimes and misdemeanors are the
lowest level offenses for which you
would impeach someone
treason and corruption are the highest
level offenses
and there is absolutely no doubt that
this president has committed treason and
that he is the most thoroughly corrupt
politician perhaps in the history of our
nation
so he meets all four criteria but most
importantly he meets the more serious
criteria
when you have a traitor in the white
house that is an emergency and i would
argue it is the constitutional duty of
the congress to impeach him
whether it's politically popular or not
so i happen to strongly disagree with
nancy pelosi about that but i do
understand why she's saying it because
practically speaking
the 2020 election is the only way that
we will remove him from office
dr john gartner has been teaching in the
department of psychiatry at johns
hopkins
medical center for 28 years founder of
duty to warn and
co-editor of rocket man nuclear madness
in the mind of donald trump dr gartner a
pleasure as always having you on
thank you always pleasure talking to you
too